Gián mề trình thân sau công an thành phó an nội tổ chức hội nghĩ thông tin bà chỉ về một số vụ việc của an đến hình về tình tế môi trường trên địa ban.
Nhưu của gồn lộ hàng ngoảnh là thực phẩm với số lượng lớn sài ra trên địa ban.
Một số của an sẽ mở tài sản giới hiện đức 1 ban chuyển nhận kinh y giú lịch.
Theo công an thành phó an nội, từ năm 2018 đến năm 2019, các đối trưởng đã thành lập 20 bệ công bý.
Để tổ chức khoảng động 1 ban môi giới và chuyển nhận các hợp đồng thể kinh y giú lịch.
Nãy gọi tâm liy muốn bị giữa giữa rã rẻ, được tăng qua và ký vọng sinh lời, các đối trượng đã giú lộ nhiều khách hàng ký hợp đồng.
Và nội tiền các loán bị giữa ấn chỉ giá từ 2 chăm đến chính trong giữa đồng.
Để tạo niềm tin, nhân viên từ vấn thường vừa ra các thăm kết về khả nắng sinh lời hoặc chuyển nhiều lại hợp đồng của giá cao.
Tuy nhiên, những nội dung này tru yếu chỉ được chá đổi bằng lời nói.
Sau khi khách hàng ký hợp đồng và nội tiền, nhiều trường hợp không thể thực hiện việc chuyển nhiều đã hử hẹn.
Và của anh trên cho thấy tổ thằng tích trế của nó, được đảm chứ gọi tài khả.
Tình vi, trả dân thật, mình không bao giờ tụi tâm đến cơm quan không biết quan đến trị trụ phía rất vui hồn.
Còn tìm và đông và đầu tư vui nạc, tìm đẹp, trị đẹp, trị đẹp.
Tính đến ngày May 3, sau, nhà chức trách đảm tiền hành khám sét một chăm chỉ miếng sảo để điểm lã nơi ở,
làm việc của các đối tượng trong các quán, của việc liên quan đến 2,5 công tiền tui giữa hợp đồng, tui phíao,
mấy tính, mấy tính, mấy tính, tâm giữ tiền tài sản của các bị cân trong của an với tổng giả trị khoảng sau trong tâm người phép bà tỷ đồng.
Gồm tiên mặt, mấy bà phía một tỷ đồng, phóng tòa tài khoảng của các đối tượng, só mấy phía chiến tỷ đồng.
Mấy một xe hô tốt các loại, mức đầu cơ quan hà nội xác định có khoảng mấy bệnh dinh hợp đồng, sở rửa kiến gì, được hai bà công ty kết,
qua đó lựa 2,5 bà trong tý đồng, truyếu tư người cao tuổi.
Đương ngày 12 tháng 6 đến ngày 18 tháng 6, cơ quan cạnh xa đều tra không hoàn thành cụ đã giả quy định
thời tổ hai mi tư buãn, khởi tổ một chăm chim mi tư bị cân, mấy tội lừa đạo chiến đoạt tài sản.
Trong đò khoảng 2 bị cân, khởi tổ hai tội xanh lừa đạo chiến đoạt tài sản và dự tiền.
Giữa những cơ quan cạnh xa đều tra không hoàn thành cụa nội đang tiếp tục tập trung điều tra mở rộng.
Lâm rõ sử liên quan của các không tý, làm rõ tàn bộ vụ an và các đường trở liên quan đây sử liên nghiêm theo quy định của pháp luật.